so Greggy refers the apocalyptic event
where nanites pretty much replicate
themselves and it basically devour the
world and leave behind a gray goo grey
goo itself is a core RTS we're basically
taking a venture with petroglyph in grey
box and going about creating a RTS
that's going back to the roots where we
we really looked at the core pillars of
RTS which is base management economic
management and strategic combat and
bringing those three things back into a
balance as a result of what's happened
over the last two decades of our of the
RTS charity so here you're looking at
the beta HQ and it's got pretty much for
connection points we just start
customizing with but we need to get our
economy up and running so we're going to
go ahead and throw down a refinery here
now we really went about grey goo and
said hey you know we want this gameplay
to be meaningful we want player choices
to have be strategic and every choice
that you interact with the game should
be something that is meaningful to the
player as a result we redesigned the way
the economics work for gray goo and not
falling so or like traditional sense in
the sense that you know you start with
your refinery you place it down you find
this you know the resource patches and
they have different density levels so
you know you can try to put it here on
the edge and maybe get eight resources
per second but then maybe if you put a
second when you might get 16 out of that
small patch or you know I'm just going
to take the easy way and say here
there's the high density I'll get 10 so
i'll just go ahead and drop it there at
this point your economies set up your
right a rock and roll and once that
building is actually finished and
constructed it's going to automatically
start the harvesters and create the
supply line for you that you get to
interact with so all the economic
gameplay of having harvesters of being
able to raid that or take out your
opponent's economy is there so you could
have either do a light rate and just hit
them for a small amount by taking the
harvester line or maybe go for the
extractor and just say hey you know what
we're going to blow this sucker
up and prettier do economy down like in
a medium impact way or do you go for the
throat but you don't just hit his
current economic status but also his
futures and just rip that down now
there's different degrees of gameplay
that come with this in the sense of you
know something the refineries are
probably very very well protected the
harvesters they're traveling across the
map they're probably something you very
much easy to do a hit and radon and
while the extractors are that middle
ground for in between it the other thing
we did for Greg is we said hey we want
to be able to take unit production and
make it meaningful for the player as
well so factories as they exist in for
gray goo are all about production volume
they create a volume of units that
you're actually able to produce not
necessarily the diversity for the betas
their base building goes into a very
unique state of going for them where
this is where the customization comes in
in the modularity here's the factory you
know it's building out and once it's
completed it's going to give you the
option for producing these two initial
units now that's all great and dandy but
when you're looking at what you have
left on this structure you have to get
two more connections the players faced
with gameplay choices do I want to throw
another factory in here and increase the
production volume or do I want to
actually create increase my diversity by
saying hey I want to build predator tank
so I'll do this tech for now we're going
to go and say hey here's the predator
tanks and we're going to go ahead and
attach a tech building here to actually
access accessorize our factory so it's
able to do it now we have this really
interesting gameplay choice for the
player what do I want to do at that last
spot is it more important for me to
increase my production volume and drop
another factory or is it more important
for you to increase the diversity these
are the choices we want
to think about when their base building
how do you build your base and let it be
customizable for you so for right now
we're going to go ahead and throw down
another factory increase our volume so
this attack once it's done is actually
convey its benefits to both of these
factories and increase the production
now with all this customization that
goes along with you probably thinking
hey well how do I manage all of this do
I have to remember which factors
configured to what we went ahead and
said hey there's this new new way for
you to actually interact and making
streamlining you can micromanage each
individual factor if you want but
throughout the hotkey system we
developed into gray goo you're actually
able to go ahead and say hey one key
press here's what I got and now choose
the subunit of what I or should want and
the game is going to go and find what
what factory is best for that to
actually be built down here you can see
that this factor is actually queued up
with our stalker and our commando and it
actually said that third hole for their
predator is actually being built over
here and now those jeans are to come out
now for the betas they're all about this
modularity and then they can also decide
whether they want to build really close
together or start distributing across
the map so if we go for a quick stroll
over here with our commando unit our
basic one of our base infantry we might
decide hey you know what I want to go
ahead and start spending out this
direction you could be dropping a powers
power hub out here in the wilderness and
say this is where I while I started
build he could proxy who build snow
outposts decide where you want to build
them across the map and just kind of
customize them the power hubs come in
like three different sizes they come in
as small which has two connections a
medium which has four and a larger chest
six and that kind of covers a little
hole of what the beta actually does for
their Facebook so there's a lot
modularity and customization good friend
here we're going to show you an example
of how the humans work remember the
beta's were all about modularity and
customization and then being that middle
of the road that you can build
distributed basis or not the humans are
actually all about building one giant
about fortress that they actually
interact with that fortress is all about
the central power core where you see
this big powerful it's generating
everything in a central computer that
powers everything now we're going to go
ahead and start our economy up and
running but the economy system for the
humans is very similar but very
different in far as the challenges that
it presents to employer so while it's
the same refinery extractor harvesters
running back and forth it's still about
well where do i need this board i'm
going to have a base that's a big base
do I really want to start with the
resources that are closest to my base or
do I want to start further away for now
we're just going to start with something
close by go get the base building here
so the base itself is actually built
around the idea that everything needs to
be connected together you're almost
playing on a small game of Tetris and
organizing and figuring out your base
layout so here we're going to go ahead
and start the factory up and running and
get it going so we have our unit
production here you can see the
harvesters coming now human harvesters
are also very different from what the
betas are in the terms of their a little
bit smaller your luck there a lot faster
and they carry a smaller load so when
their lines are rated it doesn't
necessarily have as strong of an impact
to them as it would to a beta player
since they are so very much to pace
dependent on where they're able to back
over here so here's the human factory
and we're going to get started building
the space here
te know it's a similar thing where you
get your two base units and then there's
all the additional text to be built on
to it for the human for the humans
themselves you're actually going to take
those base buildings and actually attach
them directly to the structure so that
it gets that benefit this is where that
pen that puzzle building actually really
comes into play what you're saying hey
what do how do i best maximize this
layout here's this tech building it can
being conveyed to this factory well it's
only got one other connection point to
give its tattoo so we'll just go ahead
and drop another tech or another factory
I'm sorry right here at the end of it
constructor now this once this is done
this factory will get the same bonus but
now it's been isolated also only those
two work now all that gives us selective
well that gives us the access to all
these tank units we're going to want to
expand working here we have our
howitzers which are artillery units as
well as our Lancers which are some of
our seeds so for right now we're going
to go ahead and start building some of
our seeds units so here you can see the
factory under production you can see
that the it actually has the tank tech
available so those tank units are able
to produce we'll go ahead and start
queuing not now one of the features we
really looked at as well and we didn't
quite cover this in the beta but here
here in the humans you definitely see it
is that we allow the units to be auto
cute in so you don't necessarily have to
manage what you're producing out of a
factory if you know what the staple is
that you want out of it so for example
right now this human tank is being auto
built so when this is done it's going to
go to the X to the q now I may want to
say a revolver in here as well once that
room this human tank is done the
revolver will advance forward but you
know what let's go to put a tried it
earlier too these are things like I mean
just need one or two of these units I
still want my tanks being my main staple
so we'll have this factory just
constantly producing out ready small and
here you can see how it is shifted the
line you also have the ability to say
well you know what this is more higher
priority and you get shuffle the rain
the liner on if you want this exists for
both the humans and the betas but it's
just that functionality that if you want
to micro it you can you have to know so
we're going to go in q1 of our C chips
inside tact finished now we're gonna go
ahead and drill this guy to the front of
line unit ready and there he goes now
here you can see you are killing it's
basically our tank which is right off
the Gladius over here and then our
revolver which is our heavy infantry or
as well as our Trident which is kind of
a light infantry unit for the humans an
additional that to the unit designs that
we did we really wanted to take the unit
designs and say we want to give you very
simple tools that you can use n number
of ways so that there are no of
activated abilities on the units they're
just all units that have a very specific
function that they work with and how you
want to use it it's a strategy that and
how you interact with in addition to all
of that we did say hey you know we want
to be able to allow you to change the
role on some of these units so for
example when you sort this Lancer comes
out he's going to come out with a beam
that you can actually go and just blow
up other units wet it's kinda like this
beam that's going to really be good
again structures that coors into it it
just like burns it down but that may not
be what unit so I need it for you might
have structure control as far as
destroying your enemy no problem what
you need him to do is really give you
some pump it some punch you can actually
change
the actually does as far as I his role
by through our tech upgrade system so
each of the different tech types has a
different tech upgrade for now we're
going to go ahead and say hey here we're
going to take change our Lancer instead
of I'm that quarrying beam that you can
only have we're going to get ahead and
give him a Grail gunshot all right hello
commander as you can see you know this
is starting out but we need some base
defense ready so we're going to go ahead
and add in a turd here to give us some
defense so we'll go ahead and plus one
over here and toss another one on this
side beginning construction this is
might be a great layout for our early
game we might be you know we got
everything concerned concentrated here
together we're holding off the enemy
pretty cool we got some units felt that
will definitely work towards that
advantage but you know we're ready to
push out the humans basically are these
other buildings that we call conduits
just like Michael laying down a very
long extension cable we can take it and
extend it out once it's actually done
building you can start building off of
the end of it and creating almost
redundancy to your systems like I was
saying you know this works great once
we're expanding out we're starting to
build over here we've pushed expanded
our base area these terms may not do it
I was anymore any good anymore right up
here so we're going to take the
opportunity that we're going to let you
teleport these buildings around humans
are the masters of teleportation as such
they can actually reconfigure the basis
of what they want so here we can take
say hey that turret doesn't work there
anymore we're going to move it over here
this gives the player to I did the
ability to really customize that big
fortress he's doing for the stage of the
game
early on it might be really tight and
compact late game you might be starting
to push out and you don't want to
reconfigure it to get the best
efficiency out of it now there's one
more unit type that exists for gray goo
that we really haven't kind of covered
yet I really want to show everybody so
and that is the epic glass units or
humans are going to need to build a
large factory and they're actually going
to have to create all the technologies
and directly attached to the / large
factory to gain access to these
epigenetic structure the epic units
represent everything dad was a human
commander would want to actually bring
into the battle and actually what he
wants to say hey this represents me as
to what I'm going to actually killed so
here we go doctor he's got a few seconds
here bill unfortunately while that's
going out there I'm gonna go ahead and
take a tour around the map and show you
guys some of the cool Torian that we're
actually doing so will take this force
over here we're going to go start
exploring now you saw her originally the
resource layouts and how they were kind
of laid out on the map for the starting
areas but that's not the way they
actually exist in the world so here
turning on the resource lab so you can
actually see them you can see how
there's different density in different
shapes for all the specific resources
this really gives you that economic
interaction with the map that changes
the way it is you don't necessarily just
go to one spot as to where here to get
your resources we need to go to
necessarily many as a result maybe we're
ready to go ahead and say hey we're
going to go ahead and expand out our
economy here once that's done building
it's like I is just about done large
factory complaints now all these texts
are building you can see here's the base
units going with him and you can see
what text we hurry unlocked that's
already proven motion so sorry for that
slight digression but um alright so
going around the map again kind of
talking more of the train that we have
you can see here that we have some of
this forest well the forest is actually
very tactically and strategically
significant on the map cool thing about
it is that forests are all about hiding
units and having that advantage of being
a taking a larger force on from a bright
defended position you know you might
have a few Marines that might be sick
you know in modern day that are sitting
in a tree line fighting a jungle
shooting out other soldiers are
attacking them we wanted to get take
that exact experience and give you the
ability to play with it in a wartime
game so with the forest and we do
exactly that anybody who's inside the
force can actually shoot out people who
are shooting into it can't see who's in
there so they can't actually target in
there additionally this actually
provides your ground units cover from
any aircraft that are actually flying
over all right now we wanted to show you
exactly what the a picture look like so
here's actually the human epic for the
human faction it's just giant battle
robot that has the human inside of it
that he actually taught marches across
around on the field Tracy's eclipse with
a very big energy field that when it
overloads it actually will explode
outwards and push it in hands away from
f---ing there on roots here you can see
some of the enemy's actually take all
three are out as much closer to
we decide the
come of this conflict not it we owe this
is little too much damage there
coordinates received on my way moving
addition to all that he's actually got
this big energy thing they can just cut
through an enemy army outfit here every
faction has an epic and we're really
excited to see what gameplay this brings
and actually impacts on to the base when
you bring it over and just bring that
destruction to bear so our really
explains are actually to have the game
released on Steam we're set up to do an
open alpha or sorry a closed alpha here
really shortly after packs they'll go to
closed beta and an open beta and then
we're playing to release the game on
steam on this fall in 2014